the terra ecosystem and the luna
foundation are driving the price of
bitcoin much much higher there's lots of
people who are speculating in the market
they're talking about it on twitter you
even seen some mainstream articles
written about it but here is proof that
luna foundation is the one driving the
bitcoin price higher we can see that
their reserves of bitcoin that green
line as soon as it had an inflection
point and started to go higher and
higher the bitcoin price followed and
that's because bitcoin right now is a
highly illiquid market there's not that
much bitcoin that it's in circulation
that people are willing to sell most
people have gone ahead and taken their
bitcoin off of exchanges and so that
illiquidity has been higher and higher
well if you have an illiquid market and
there's a persistent buyer that's going
to spend billions of dollars in the
market of course the price is going to
go higher and that's exactly what we're
watching and so if you want to
understand what happens with bitcoin's
price over the next couple of weeks one
great metric to pay attention to is the
bitcoin reserve number for the luna
foundation if they continue to buy as
they've stated that they will i expect
the bitcoin price to grow higher and
higher simply because we have an
illiquid market a persistent buyer and
if you're a fan of supply and demand
economics the price has to move upwards
to accommodate everyone ultimately luna
is taking a big bet to back that usc
stablecoin with bitcoin but bitcoin
holders whether you like it or you don't
it doesn't matter because they're having
a positive impact on the price and
ultimately everybody understands bitcoin
is pristine collateral bitcoin is for
everyone and now as ust becomes backed
by bitcoin bitcoins also serving as a
price indicator of just how much is luna
buying hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time